I'm putting plastic beads and LED shot
into a cylinder so now I'm going to
shake this in the same way and of course
being a theoretician it's not going to
work but after a while you can begin to
see regions where it's darker and region
where it's red and you keep doing this
for a while I'm going to be talking
about what's called the Brazil nut
effect and in that there's a capital
gamma which is somewhat like a hangman's
jib it is the ratio of acceleration to
gravity well let's suppose I shake this
up and down gravity acting downwards has
an acceleration of 9.8 meters per second
if I raise this up slowly then nothing
much moves but if I shake it violently
at the top part there's an acceleration
and the packing inside will hit the top
of the box so you're hearing rattling up
and down so the Brazil nut effect comes
I think it was first thought of in about
1930 people notice that if you had a
packet of cereal such as this one which
is loosely when you open the packet of
Mosley first thing in the morning the
heavier particles the big ones are on
the top you've got well I can point out
a Brazil nut there and a cashew nut and
some raisins and down the bottom it's
almost mixed up but if I kick shavings
like this eventually you will find at
the top and it will take quite a while
there's an Armin nut and there's a
Kishin nut and all the big particles
come there or your you've got your
coffee you know instant coffee and it's
you shake it up just to mix it all up
and you'll find the bigger grains going
on the top and the smaller ones
underneath that's what you're trying to
do when you when you BIG's up your
cereal you're trying to get it uniformly
spread but when you try and do these
things nature plays a trick on you but
it doesn't go the way you would imagine
let me just show you this nice simple
demonstration here I've got brains
they're green and a little steel ball on
the top so if I arrange matters so the
steel ball is on the bottom
and I shake this up and down for about
10-15 settings after a while you'll
notice the ball has come to the top
it's a ratcheting effect the smaller
particles get underneath it then you
throw it up more small particles get
underneath it and it goes up to the top
here we have two plates of glass
separated by gaff about three
millimeters with little glass spheres
and we put bigger particles we used
aluminium particles but these are steel
washers with roughly the same size and
put them in there originally the
research student Duncan Saunders did the
computing and he said you put them in
there and they are all clustered
together and we have a video showing his
computed results and so the computed
results suggested that these particles
will come together like a little swarm
of bees and cluster around each other in
the middle which is quite the opposite
of what you would expect because what
you want to do when you're shaking this
up is make everything as dispersed as
possible so we did the experiment nobody
believed that you could actually do the
experiment and the results are shown in
the in the video and it starts out with
particles which are reasonably close
together and you shake it up and after a
while they act like a little song of
bees all buzzing around each other and
I'd like to show you finally this
experiment I did it a couple of days ago
I'm putting plastic beads and LED shot
into a cylinder the red ones are the
plastic beads the black ones are the
tiny little pieces of lid they have the
same sizes and you shake this about and
you try and mix it up and you can't do
it but it's relatively well mixed and I
can use the same parameter gamma I now
have the horizontal version of
acceleration which we always measure in
terms of gravity and then you put in a
little bit of water not a lot just a
little bit you see the water going in
filling through the whole cell right
down to the bottom and now you have
beads moving in water which you would
think that's not going to make any
difference
so now I'm going to shake this in the
same way and of course being a
theoretician it's not going to work
but after a while you can begin to see
regions where it's darker and region
where it's red and you keep doing this
for a while and you find patterns
emerging
this black red black red black red black
red black red it goes into stripes so
you have a mechanism for pattern
formation but why it turns out to be
these particular spacing between is a
bit of a mystery is that five minutes
yep well